schnallen sie sich besser an denn es
erwarten sie haar sträubende aufnahmen
ob reingefahren oder platt gemacht
haarscharf vorbei
oder mittenrein
kleine kameras auf dem armaturenbrett
sogenannte des camps zeichnen gnadenlos
alles auf
in vielen ländern boomt der markt für
des camps die aufnahmen sollen bei
unfällen als beweismittel dienen und vor
betrügern schützen die abkassieren
wollen
kein wunder also dass immer mehr
verblüffende videoclips im umlauf sind
halten sie sich gut fest wir starten
unsere reise um die welt mit bildern die
ihnen garantiert den atem
los geht's
das sind die spektakulärsten des camps
und keine sorge
niemand wird hier ernsthaft verletzt
auch wenn es manchmal knapp wird
richtig knapp heute haben wir es mit
verzweifelten betrügern
völlig verunglückten rückwärtsfahren zu
tun
wir zeigen ihnen die gefahren beim
radfahren und bekommen ist mit einem
fluss gehört zu tun
[Musik]
hast du ein bisschen kleingeld
heutzutage wird einem an jeder ecke das
geld aus der tasche gezogen der
straßenverkehr ist keine ausnahme
ein grund für den boom von des games sie
können helfen betrügern das handwerk zu
legen
[Musik]
und die idioten sterben nicht aus indem
sie sich vor fremde autos werfen wollen
sie sich geld vom fahrer erpressen bitte
lächeln sie wurden gefilmt
dieser typ ihr beherrscht das timing
noch nicht so richtig wenn man an einem
zebrastreifen von einem auto angefahren
wird dann meistens bevor es angehalten
hatte
jetzt diskutieren nicht noch die leine
der bei fahrrad genug und verscheucht
den übeltätern
in der fahrschule lernt man so einiges
aber fußgänger die sich auf die
motorhaube werfen stehen eigentlich
nicht auf dem lehrplan
[Musik]
hier kommt eine warnung an alle die
anhalten um pannen hilfe zu leisten
dieser typ hier kommt angeblich aus
deutschland
[Musik]
das problem seine kreditkarte
funktioniert nicht also braucht er
bargeld
rauf mit dem fenster fahren einfach
weiter ich hab leider nur 20
[Musik]
um himmels willen ruft die polizei und
fahr los hallo polizei viel erfolg
größer
einen erwachsenen abzuziehen ist die
eine sache aber ein kind wir kennen die
genauen hintergründe nicht aber die wahl
des abfalls und des fahrzeugs scheinen
mehr als ungewöhnlich zum glück sind die
stützräder noch dran sonst hätte das
übel enden können
[Musik]
hier sehen wir einige laiendarsteller
die sich an einer tragödie versuchen
solche vorstellungen können wunderbar
sein vorausgesetzt die schauspieler
haben talent
ist dass in diesem stück der fall sie
braucht offensichtlich noch etwas übung
[Musik]
ich habe ihn schon aus einem kilometer
entfernung kommen sehen ist hier kaum
eine übertreibung wenn man sich schon
vor ein auto werfen will sollte man
unbedingt das überraschungsmoment für
sich nutzen und außerdem den hund zu
hause lassen denn der wird er nicht
freiwillig in ein auto laufen wer will
gassi gehen und geld abziehen der feinde
rund
[Musik]
außer kontrolle
wenn jemand die kontrolle über sein
fahrzeug verliert kann das verschiedene
ursachen haben
fehlendes fahrerisches können ein
blackout oder ein einschätzungsvermögen
das na ja nicht ganz so gut ist
meistens ist aber natürlich jemand
anders die straße oder das auto selbst
dass ich einfach selbstständig macht
ein kurzer blick aufs handy und dieser
wagen streifte die mittelleitplanke
der fahrer verliert die kontrolle
und nimmt noch ein anderes auto mit
der unfall sieht spektakulär aus doch
beide fahrer waren angeschnallt und
keiner kam zu schaden
ein kurzer moment der unachtsamkeit
reicht schon aus das taxi bremst und der
fahrer dahinter reagiert zu spät
er fährt gegen den bordstein und der
wagen überschlägt sich die düsen de
mitfahrerin ist jetzt sicher wach
einige leute eilen zu hilfe zum glück
bleiben alle unverletzt
kann mal jemand ein taxi rufen
eine fahrt durch einen an sich ruhigen
vorort in england
die reaktion
typisch britisch
an baustellen muss man manchmal warten
und den entgegenkommenden verkehr vorbei
lassen
vor allem wenn ein bagger auf einen zug
fährt hallo ich habe doch brav gewartet
vielleicht war die lenkung kaputt
vielleicht wollte der arbeiter aber auch
einfach alle autos von der straße haben
wie auch immer die fahrerin des jeeps
ist nicht begeistert
[Musik]
wir menschen brauchen vielleicht
maschinen aber die maschinen brauchen
uns menschen nicht
dieses dreirad versucht zu entkommen
endlich frei endlich frei
diese polizisten sind ratlos ist dieses
auto von einem dämon besessen ist es
einem stephen king roman entsprungen
hier helfen weder taser noch pistolen
alles was sie tun können ist abwarten zu
sehen und hoffen dass der tank leer ist
[Musik]
und danach gibt es erst mal donuts
dieser bauarbeiter spielt in der
mittagspause eine runde fangen mit
seinem bagger
könnte eine weile dauern
und tut es auch
der bagger fährt immer weiter im kreis
und hat seinen spaß
dann hat er genug vernascht einen
radfahrer und legt sich nur runde hin
vorsicht viele
tiere haben auf der autobahn eigentlich
nichts verloren andererseits was war
zuerst da das huhn oder die straße
außerdem ist doch schön so im einklang
mit der natur
ja doch du hast vorfahrt tschuldigung
[Musik]
alter die kameraeinstellung überzeugt
mich nicht ich zeig dir wie es geht
dieser hund will wohl unbedingt den job
des kameramanns
oder vielleicht doch nicht
[Musik]
kilometerlang freiestrasse sonne und
kein hindernis in sicht
alles klar bei dir
für den fahrer ist das hier eine
überflutete straße für das krokodil ist
es der amazonas du kannst gerne hupen
aber ein reptil das seit 100 millionen
jahren auf der erde lebt wird sich
deswegen nicht hetzen sei nur froh dass
du im auto sitzt und das nächste mal
zeigt etwas mehr respekt
flusspferde können bis zu 30
stundenkilometer schnell rennen und auch
im wasser sind sie sehr schnell wenn sie
also in einem triathlon gegen ein
flusspferd antreten sollten sie
unbedingt auf dem fahrrad einen
ordentlichen vorsprung herausfahren
wer kennt das nicht der morgen nach
einer durchzechten nacht
[Musik]
ich bitte sprich nicht so laut ich komm
ja schon
[Musik]
eichhörnchen sind ziemlich clever aber
auch foul nächstes mal drückt doch bitte
den
gänse laufen gern in reih und glied und
gänse lassen sich ungern hetzen
die internationalen spannungen nehmen zu
nordkorea mobilisiert all seine reserven
diese enten spezialeinheit marschiert in
perfekter ordnung über den zebrastreifen
sie demonstriert linientreue und
disziplin zieh dich warm an donald
das kennen wir doch alle die kneipe ist
so und alle freunde schon nach hause
gegangen wo kriege ich jetzt noch einen
döner her
die karnevalsparty war echt der hammer
man kann da kostüm hat alle umgehauen
panda ich bin ein panda ich wohne lieber
was vom chinesen
erkennen sie warum der motorradfahrer
stürzt
wenn sie genau hinsehen erkennen sie ein
loses stromkabel in dem sich das
motorrad verfängt zum glück gibt es
helme
dreh dich um
wenn man rückwärts fährt sollte man
darauf achten was hinter einem ist
außerdem ist es ganz gut er langsam zu
fahren
wenn man sich an dieser simplen regeln
hält ist es eigentlich ganz einfach
wenn nicht kann es auch mal schiefgehen
so wie hier zum beispiel
[Musik]
dieser manier hat offenbar zu viel reis
wein intus jetzt will er heimweh ist ihm
egal
zum glück saß niemand draußen ein teurer
ausflug ist es trotzdem
13.500 euro kostet der schaden ein taxi
wäre billiger gewesen
[Musik]
nach 40 jahren übung denkt man sollte
dieser mann hier seine einfach kennen
nur dass er heute zum zehnten mal in die
mauer seines nachbarn kraft deshalb die
kamera beim rückwärtsfahren sollte man
immer in den rückspiegel gruppen dieser
fahrer hier guckt offenbar woanders hin
und die dame scheint zu viel walking
dead gesehen zu haben
hallo auch zombies sollten auf den
verkehr achten
da steht sie schon wieder wie eine eins
gehen nicht zu der frau
[Musik]
wer eine bank überfällt braucht einen
guten fluchtwagenfahrer er sollte den
weg kennen schnell reagieren und vor
allem den richtigen gang rein kriegen
der hier hat wohl eher keine große
zukunft als krimineller
[Musik]
autofahrer brauchen voraussicht gute
reaktionen und die richtigen
straßenschilder um sicher ans ziel zu
kommen
wenn die straßenschilder die fahrer
verwirren ist das ein problem wie man
hier sieht
[Musik]
gleiche kreuzung anderes szenario was
machen die denn da
sie haben vielleicht mitgekriegt dass
hier eine kamera hängt und wollen das
kennzeichen verdecken
das wird so nicht funktionieren
der bescheid kommt dann per post
jetzt geht's nach indien der sebastian
vettel unter den rückwärts tuk tuk waren
beeindruckt alle mit seinem fahrkönnen
und verdiente sich so den siebten titel
in folge sein ziel für nächstes jahr
vorwärts fahren
jetzt wird's ungemütlich
schlechtes wetter bedeutet oft auch
starke winde im gegensatz zu schnee oder
regen kann man sie aber nicht sehen ab
geschwindigkeiten von 110 kilometer pro
stunde kann der wind schon bäume
ausreißen und dächer abdecken
wie anfällig ein auto ist hängt von
seiner aerodynamik ab eine kräftige böe
kann der vaart durchaus ein ende setzen
im zweifelsfall lieber schutz suchen und
anhalten
große laster sind besonders in gefahr
denn sie bieten mehr angriffsfläche
hier sieht vielleicht aus wie ein
sonniger tag auf dem highway aber es
herrschen starke seitenwinde und an der
straße stehen weder bäume noch gebäude
was sie hier hören sind windböen die an
die seite des trucks schlagen und dann
manchmal läuft es eben einfach schief
[Musik]
wenn ein laster das warnblinklicht
einschalten sollte man abstand halten
und das gleiche tun was passiert kann
man jetzt wohl schon armen
am besten man lässt den dingen ihren
lauf und ist hoffentlich gut
angeschnallt
[Musik]
auch in verkehrsmeldungen wird oft vor
sperrten seitenwinden gewarnt
und wie dieser taifun in thailand
demonstriert sollte man was durchaus
ernst nehmen
von einer brücke hat man oft eine tolle
aussicht aber man ist auch den elementen
schutzlos ausgesetzt auf einer brücke in
großbritannien findet dass dieses
pärchen zuerst lustig
vielleicht nicht mehr so
[Musik]
ist das gerade wirklich passiert
glauben sie an karma
[Musik]
wind ist für manche jahr ein zeichen von
gott ok dann gibt er hier also zeichen
mit einem verkehrszeichen
aber jetzt wissen die fahrer nicht mehr
wo sie abheben sollen die wege des herrn
sind unergründlich
um robert de niro in taxi driver zu
zitieren eines tages wird ein großer
regen diesen ganzen abschaum von der
straße spielen hier in china town
erledigt das der welt sehr zum ärger der
mopedfahrer die eigentlich einen helm
tragen sollten am ende sieht es aus als
hätte eine wildgewordene kuhherde lauter
fladen hinterlassen ich mach das nicht
sauber
[Musik]
da kriegt man echt angst dieser
aufblasbare mond wird vom wind über die
straße getrieben so bekommt das wort
mondlandung eine ganz andere bedeutung
spaß auf zwei rädern
radfahrer entweder man mag sie dann ist
man meistens selber einer oder man hasst
sie und sie nerven radfahrer und
autofahrer sind äußerst selten nett
zueinander
das leben als radfahrer ist gefährlich
und dann muss man auch noch auf die
fußgänger achten
gegen ein auto
zieht man meistens den kürzeren
in den niederlanden ist das fahrrad das
verkehrsmittel in der stadt
dieser kollege hier ist von der dame vor
ihm abgelegt er will unbedingt dran
bleiben doch das glück verlässt ihn
vielleicht ist heute nicht sein tag
die radlerin hat sich in luft aufgelöst
ihr verfolger achtet nicht mehr auf den
verkehr
[Musik]
eine kleine delle aber hier in den
niederlanden hilft auch mal ein
autofahrer einem radfahrer bei einer
panne
camden market in london hier kann man
prima einkaufen oder sich tätowieren
lassen aber in london fahrrad zu fahren
ist wie eine party russisch roulette
dieser rücksichtslose fahrer kommt
gefährlich nahe
[Musik]
empfohlen wird ein abstand von etwa
einem meter zwischen auto und fahrrad
vorschrift ist das allerdings nur in
wenigen ländern in
solchen situationen ist es immer gut
eine kamera dabei zu haben es gibt immer
wieder leute die bei radlern rot sehen
und sehr telegen sind
wer vorausschauend fährt kann unfälle
vermeiden doch leider weiß man dann noch
nicht was vielleicht gerade von hinten
kommt
das war eindeutig absicht
glücklicherweise wurde dieser angriff
des fahrers aufgezeichnet die
kalifornische polizei fackelt nicht
lange und nimmt ihn fest ab in die zelle
mit ihm
ein anderer radfahrer ein anderer
aggressiver autofahrer in neuseeland
zeichnen zwei kameras auf wie ein suv
diesen radfahrer absichtlich anfährt und
von der straße befördert der mann wurde
wegen rücksichtslosen fahrens angeklagt
warum fahren die größten idioten nur
immer die dicksten autos
auch dieser bmw fahrer bestätigt so
manches vorurteil
er sieht vor die radfahrer und bremst
abrupt die können nicht mehr reagieren
glücklicherweise reagiert der
fahranfänger dahinter schnell gut
gemacht
diesmal ist der radfahrer schuld oben
links
[Musik]
er rast über die straße in ein
entgegenkommendes auto
game over
seine beine zittern nicht nur wegen des
unfalls nach ein paar nachmittäglichen
drinks hätte er sich lieber nicht auf
die straße begeben sollen nein der fährt
heute nirgendwo mehr hin
zu guter letzt
straßenrennen der anderen art viel spaß
[Musik]